[Music]
what's up y'all we've got dana cub here
we've got leslie grace from in the
heights there
that's right they're stretching it out
you want to know why
because derek is a legendary dancer and
leslie kills it in her new musical
and i'm just well amazing at everything
so it's time for a game
we're calling dance battle double down
[Music]
get it jeff you know what jesse i think
we're going to need another person over
here and i pick you
from the band yeah i want that you know
oh you're going to take your earrings
off too what's happening
too are we coming to play jesse
it's going to be jessie and leslie
versus the winners
derek and me now we just need a host so
god are you there lord
hey kelly i was just tending to my
garden you like apples
i'm just playing how are you doing girl
how are you doing
i am good still a little mad that i'm
not invited in but
thanks for helping with the game so
could you tell us how it works
well kelly this is a dance game so i'm
going to read a question
and the answer to that question will be
the name of a dance
okay now if you know the dance be the
first to jump up on that platform and
give the answer
now if you're right you'll have a chance
to double down
for another point by doing the dance
for my own amusement now we're going to
play in rounds
kelly against jesse and derek against
leslie now if kelly wins
if you win kelly the right side of our
house seats will get a cool
prize but if not the left side will win
okay so let's get kelly and jesse up
there first come on now
oh wait it's us first oh that's right
that's right let's do it listen to the
voice of god now
good luck here is your first question
okay
what dance move was pioneered by alfonso
ribeiro on the freshman
kelly what is the name the name of the
dance name of the dance
it's not unusual carlton it is the
carlton now
for double the points can you do the
dance let's get some music
[Applause]
please all right that's enough now come
on now derek and leslie it's your turn
get up there
okay it's me now here's your question
get it
derek you look so sexy in that jacket
let me just tell you
okay here's your question the terminator
r2d2
and wall-e are examples of what
the robot they are and for double the
points can you do the robot music please
that robot don't need no oil on those
joints let me tell you kelly and jesse
come on get up there let's go again
okay here's the question
here's a question okay okay 4-0 by the
way so let's get it together here you go
thank you here's the question
when something totally unexpected
happens in a movie
you would say it's a plot what
we got now hold on hold on i'm gonna say
it's a dance-off ladies and gentlemen we
have ourselves
a tie so it's a dance-off are you ready
for my name
am i freaking out because i'm kind of
remembering how to do this
all right so the dance is called the
twist the twist
yeah and maestro please let's see the
twist
go for y'all
[Music]
i got to say jesse is the winner of the
12th guy
[Applause]
oh there he is derek and leslie it's all
you come on i'm losing from this is it
we got time for one more here we go now
last question here it is if some dude is
working out
very very hard on a treadmill what would
you call them
you see someone derek now now hold on
now this is worth triple by the way i'm
throwing in a wrench here
please derek is it the running mate it
is the running man
and for and for double the points can
you do the running man
music please
[Music]
would you like to see my twist again
[Music]
that is it here we go that's it that
means kelly and derek are the big
winners along with the right side of the
audience but kelly
i know you and i know you probably want
to give the prize to everybody so just
go ahead
everyone is a winner swig is a fashion
oriented drinkware brand that offers a
variety of insulated tumblers with
designs
that match current trends and your own
personal style everyone in the house
seats is getting a hundred dollar sweet
gift card paper food
[Applause]
thank you so much for playing and losing
um
i will say your twist is really good
jesse yes leslie's movie in the heights
is in theaters starting tomorrow and
derek show
high school musical the musical the
series is on disney plus
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help